Hong Kong is in turmoil over China's
newly proposed national security law
following last year's widespread
anti-government demonstrations scuffles
broke out inside Hong Kong's legislature
overnight when pro-democracy members
protested the bill ramie inocencia
reports on China's newest effort to
tighten its grip on the territory and
crack down on critics communist leaders
convened in Beijing for China's annual
Congress and immediately zeroed in on
their target Hong Kong we will stop
violence and restore order chairman Wang
young announced suggesting the autonomy
Hong Kong enjoys under one country two
systems' was no longer on the table it
seems like this that china plans to
subvert anti-government protests led by
what they describe as terrorists and a
threat to national security the
Communist Party has now revealed a
controversial plan to bring Hong Kong
which appealed banning trees secession
the announcement comes as protesters
readied for another summer of discontent
on Mother's Day
riot police chased pro-democracy flash
mobs calling for Hong Kong's unpopular
chief executive Carrie Lam to resign
last month police arrested 15 of the
city's top pro-democracy icons from
politicians to lawyers and activists
technically just nothing we can do to
challenge it because Washington is now
condemning Beijing's plan as a crackdown
on Hong Kong the US Senate is
introducing a bill a bipartisan one that
would sanction any Chinese official who
would enforce those new national
security laws